hi uh Alex P Keaton sophomore
Hospitality committee
congratulations
or was your favorite co-star to kiss my
wife
that's easy I just remember that
terrifying first week on Family Ties and
being more scared than anything else I'd
ever done I felt she brought the
character and my work to a new level
just purely by her presence and by the
quality of her work I do not have
to start seeing her when she was on the
show yes it wasn't love at first sight
Miss Nancy McKeon and Mr Michael Fox in
fact at the Time Michael was dating the
facts of LifeStar and Tracy was in a
long-term relationship with footloose's
Kevin Bacon
so a couple years later when I ran into
her again and we started seeing each
other of all the great things that have
come from this show Tracy obviously is
by far and away the best
E.T was there for the couple's first red
carpet together at the Emmys the
following July their Vermont wedding
created a media frenzy photographers
staked out the ceremony on the ground
and in the sky
it was very small it was maybe 50 60
people and then about 300 press people
outside trying to trying to get in
certain members of uh the print media
were upset that they couldn't get in so
I picked up a newspapers and some
magazines and I saw that that we got bad
reviews I said honey our wedding got bad
reviews so our wedding was another whole
surreal thing but it was great and it
stuck
it took which is all that matters
but Michael and Tracy had one important
rule for their relationship keep their
personal and professional lives separate
you know confuses a marriage when you
become you know that Hollywood couple
you know and and instead of worrying
about how you your your your marriage is
going you're worrying about what your
gross is wondering how your box office
was and you you know you can't measure
your relationship that way we're a
marriage first and a family first and we
just happen to both do the same thing
for a living the two made an exception
and reunited on screen in 1997 playing
High School sweethearts on an episode of
Spin City Tracy hasn't worked in this
form since family many times does it
feel good to be back in the groove of it
well this is the perfect schedule I mean
here in New York and all weekends are
free and you know the Hiatus is so so
it's actually like being married to a
normal person
that's been fun hanging together this
week and it's hard to believe but this
summer they'll celebrate their 35th
Anniversary so through all the trials
and tribulations how have you made that
marriage work it's so cliche but we just
really like each other we're most happy
in each other's company and we make each
other laugh you have said that you had
this huge crush on Tracy do you still
have that crush more more than ever
every every day there's nothing else you
could say right
just absolutely I totally have a crush
on her she's great she's my best friend
and then she's so sexy as hell and
it's great
[Music]